um so i'm going to tell you
a bit about some of the history of women
in tech
i guess the best way to start is back
about
15 years ago or so i was sitting in a
dorm room
in college and i was like well i'm the
only female in a bunch of my classes
and it was engineering classes business
classes
math classes and i'm just like why am i
the only one
and i couldn't be the only one who would
be interested in this and in future
classes i would notice there's always
that one girl like really and so i had
to wonder
first of all was there ever women in
technology who
made some significant contributions who
we could use as role models
and so i ended up doing some research
online and found
all sorts of of contributions in all
different parts of the industry
and so today we're going to talk about
some of the ladies who did make an
impact
to the technical world and we'll talk
about ada lovelace
we'll talk about the ladies of the eniac
we will talk about grace marie hopper
talk about barbara liskoff francis allen
mary lou jepson i'm going to start of
course
with ada lovelace she was born in 1815
her name was augusta ada byron lady
lovelace but
we commonly know her as ada lovelace
she was born to the famous poet lord
byron
shortly after she was born though her
parents separated and her mother raised
her
and her mom did not want her to turn
into the poet that her dad was
she was just like no and so
back in those days mathematics
and sciences were traditionally
considered a
male's topic the ladies just would not
do that they were trained more for
social for society appearances and for
taking care of things at home
but lady byron wanted to make sure that
her daughter
had skills that would steer her far from
that whole
poet imagination side so she thinks
well let's get her tutors in math and
science and maybe she'll just stay away
from that
i'm in 1828 while she was playing around
with
with something she ended up drawing a
flying machine and i'm sure her mom saw
whatever she was drawing like oh that's
pretty cool looking
it's not poetry so this is good right
but at the same time when you're born
from
parents with that kind of talent you
can't neglect it
so she asked her mom she's like if you
can't give me poetry
can't you give me political science or
like poetical science
what is that um and it's just one of
those
because she was born to a creative
person
she happened to have that creative
mindset that i want to do something
really awesome
and put my creativity into it and so
it was one of those how could she do
that
so her mathematic mind because she was
tutored
in math she just couldn't help that math
mindset and i'm sure plenty of us here
can also relate
i'm definitely one to say i understand
where she's going with that
but then she had this runaway
imagination i mean come on drawing
flying machines
that's pretty cool but that's also going
to take a lot of imagination
and she also liked to talk about
mathematics and metaphors
and so we've got something pretty
analytical pretty straightforward cut
and dry
plus then you get the creative side that
doesn't sound like it's a good
combination and then you get metaphors
which
i was like oh crazy confusion um
but for aydah that was magic
for her that was her world that was what
she lived in and
she only lived till she was in her
mid-30s she unfortunately followed in
her father's footsteps in that kind of
path as well
but in that short amount of time she was
able to contribute a lot more
so when she was 17 years old through her
friend mary
summerville she met this man here this
guy is known as charles babbage
i'm sure if you've been in the industry
long enough you've heard of him
he did the difference engine the
analytical engine
but aydah studied under him
and what was nice with him his
background so he's got mathematics
he's got philosophy he's a mechanical
engineer and he's an event an inventor
so he's got
similar mindsets to her so that made it
even easier for her to learn from him
and ada did have a life outside of just
studying from him as she grew older and
as she would get married and have a
family
she also was socializing with various
people the times
so it wasn't just she was studying under
this guy
she also had a life it's like both of us
here i mean we're here learning about
programming languages and
awesomeness that happens in our
community but then we go home
and while we're still doing this kind of
stuff we also have our families
or other things so eva had this kind of
similar
what i like to call it sometimes a
normal life
and so she's the wife of earl lovelace
and at one point she had three kids
under eight
that's a handful
mind you well she had these three kids
under eight she didn't give up her
career
she was still working with charles
babbage on this stuff but he was
studying at the time so she was juggling
both career
and children
in 1843 she was still working with
babbage
and she had some ideas for his
analytical engine
and some of the things that she
predicted what they would eventually be
used for
include things like compose complex
music
or produce graphics and then eventually
there will be practical and scientific
use
1843. here we are today now in 2013
and we have computers that do that but
this this was the
long predecessor of computers
and if they could predict what we're
doing now back then
i can only imagine what we're going to
be doing in the future but these are
ada's predictions
so she had that imagination that insight
and now look at where we're at today to
have that that was pretty cool
in terms of what she did with the
analytical engine and she documented it
for
babbage and she included the first what
is considered the first program so
basically what she did is
she showed how to calculate a sequence
of the bernoulli numbers
using the engine this is part of her
documentation
so the first computer program was
documented
how many of you guys have actually seen
code documented so nicely
i mean where we're at today how many of
you guys run into these things or you're
using code and you're like
well there's no documentation for that
well i got to see how this is going to
work
oh i hope this works like it's supposed
to
but she actually documented it so there
was none of that mystery
it was pretty cool and then to be able
to add her own words to it
and it's a significant uh contribution
and she's the first individual to to
create a computer algorithm when you
think of it that way
it's on paper it's proof that's pretty
cool
in 1843 she published in the english
science
english science journal with just her
initials
but they were able to prove that it was
her but she did on how codes can be
created to handle letters numbers
and sybils well if we can change all
those into code
then use it on this analytical engine
sounds like we got programming
so some of the things we can learn from
ada
follow your passion she got her poetical
science
she was able to put her imagination to
use and it
led her to create a computer program i
mean nowadays we write computer programs
and
for some of us it's just it seems so
natural but for her
she did it not only did it but
documented it to
where people could actually follow along
and understand it
something else we can learn is that moms
can work while maintaining a social life
in a career
and she was still socializing with
friends while she was creating this
documentation
and at the same time three kids under
eight i mean seriously
how many of you out there are parents
with three kids under eight
trying to juggle your family life your
career life
and a social life on top of that it's
pretty
significant
then choose a mentor who you're
interested in learning from
as aydah did she found somebody who had
the passion that she had
but had the experience that she didn't
have just yet
and she was able to not only learn from
him but she was also
there were documents of her and charles
babbage going back and forth on these
things
and with her excitement for it he was
able to feed off of that so he would get
excited about it and then she'd get
excited and he'd get excited
and so not only did she have a mentor
she could learn from
but she could take in from his
excitement and his energy
and also contribute back which is a good
thing in a mental relationship if you
can contribute back
i mean everybody wins
now after ada we had this thing called
the eniac
and it was a huge
huge computer thing took up a large
amount of space and these are some of
the pictures
of some of the ladies that are involved
with the eniac
and i've talked with some of my friends
and they're just like oh we see these
pictures
were those like some ladies who just
happened to volunteer there
no they were actually people who work
there these are ladies who actually
wrote the programs who
also they documented their stuff too
again documentation this is more the
eniac of course as you can see
lots and lots of cables lots of knobs
and tubes
and if you haven't seen maniac it's
phenomenal to see i had a chance to see
it when i was in dc
uh a few years back at the smithsonian
and so to see all the knobs and tubes
and the
in the dials and to see where computers
went from there to where we're at today
i mean
i'm presenting on a surface pro so we're
talking little guy
so to go from that to this phenomenal
so we're going to take a look at some of
the ladies who are involved with the
eniac
we're going to start first with k
mcnulty
she is one of these ladies here in this
picture
there were six original programmers of
the eniac
she's one of the original her background
was in mathematics
now this is something you're going to
see that's pretty common throughout
all the the women in in tech is that
they have some kind of scientific or
engineering kind of background
so we've got mathematics here she
started with ballistic
trajectories and then just happened into
the eniac they had said okay we need you
to go on to this project
and it happened to be where the eniac
was
after the eniac she ended up working on
the binac and the univac one software
design
so she stayed in the computing world
and eventually she would marry one of
the eniac co-inventors
i have to point that out there are times
where you are going to run into somebody
in the field who might be married to
somebody else in the field
and i've met people who are like oh
we're not too sure of mixing
or bringing the same people it's going
to be weird fights but for them it
really worked because he would encourage
her
to continue down that path
then there's uh jean bartik
and she's in this picture actually
so one of there were two people seeing
this other program
which we'll talk about here in a little
bit they were responsible for
administering the master programmer
they called it the master programmer it
was the central spot
for the eniac code so it was like
essentially the main core the eniac
helped they helped transform the eniac
into something a little bit easier to
work with
and they helped make it a little more
able to handle more sophisticated
problems
so of course the enact that they got was
primitive and they found ways to improve
upon it
and weren't afraid to make suggestions
on how to improve it
again after the eniac g2 moved on and
stayed in the computing world
and went to binac in univac 1.
marlin weskoff meltzer she's also
one of the original eniac programmers
she was hired before the enix she was
hired to do
weather calculations so weather
calculations
and then she also moved into ballistics
trajectories
and then moved into eniac so this is
another pattern that i noticed with the
eniac women
at least for that time so we're talking
back when this was here ballistics
trajectories and other
mathematic computations like that were
were common
and so you're going to see that with a
lot of the other ones they all have this
ballistics trajectories
example
so we've got betty snyder holberton
she's in this picture as well she's the
other one who is responsible for the
master programmer
took two of them to wrangle this thing
uh she moved on to become part of the
univac one code team
she also became part of the cobalt
committee we'll hear more about cobalt
later she also worked on developing
standards for fortran
which we'll hear a little mention of
fortran later too
so we're talking they went from the old
technology
to a computer that took up forever
amount of space
to slightly newer technology
newer compared to the eniac and a lot
more
improved a lot less shorter and probably
a lot less work
fran bilas her background was in math
and physics
and also worked on ballistics
trajectories
all these ballistics trajectories and
she was also one of the first india
computer programmers
not really documented too much as to
what was going on with her
ruth lichterman her background was in
math
and after the eniac was done in its
initial
assignment it got moved on
and ruth followed along and ruth had a
job
that i imagine if i were alive back then
i would hope to have something similar
her job was to teach future programmers
how to actually work with this beast
known as the eniac
and how to improve upon it and so i i
think that's pretty cool that they were
trying to keep the technology going and
bringing up the next generation
now adele goldstein
make sure you guys know her name
she was the one who was responsible for
training some of these ladies who are
doing ballistics trajectories
she's training them on calculating the
firing table
trajectories so again those trajectories
just don't go away
but she wrote the documentation for the
eniac we were talking documentation
again
something that we in modern day
programming don't always see
back then they actually did it
and she created this report on the eniac
to explain
the eniac is to number one how is it
built
all the way down to the resistors so
we're talking the
electronics behind it and then how do
you use it as well
these two ladies here are not part of
the original
six they were part of the next class the
next
100 programmers but as you can see
there were still women who were doing
programming on this crazy eniac
i say crazy because the intensity the
length of it the amount of work that you
had to do behind it
was a lot more than just the simple okay
let's type a couple letters here and
there let's add a semicolon here curly
braces there
it was more like we got to wire this
stuff up
and i love this quote when i saw it i
was just like this is
crazy to think about but when you think
about it the eniac
had a calculator with 18 000 vacuum
tubes and weighed 30 tons
30 tons i mean how many of you guys are
going to put
a 30 ton machine in your back and then
haul it down to the conference center
it just doesn't happen and then
they hope that maybe one day computers
only have a thousand vacuums
and weigh one and a half tons this was
1949.
2013 our computers weigh a lot less than
one and a half ton so i hope
that if they were still alive they could
see that change
because how many of you guys really
would want to be hauling around
one and a half tons of computer yeah
all right the next lady i want to
mention is admiral grace marie hopper
now leading up to today i had been
running into people being at the hotel
or when we're out
and they're like sarah are you going to
mention grace hopper are you going to
mention grace hopper i'm like
are you guys really asking me this
question um because
the thing is if you don't know about
grace hopper well you're first of all
you're in the good spot
i'll tell you all sorts of stories but
second of all
i mean her contributions are so
significant that
even in college i knew of grace murray
hopper and her contributions
it was one of those i can't hold her
back i can't leave her off of this list
of
women that were visiting in tech
she enjoyed tearing things apart and
learning how they worked i'm sure how
many of you guys do that
should see a bunch of hands up i mean
we're programmers we have to tear things
apart in order to write our programs to
make them work properly
so admiral hopper she had her background
it was math and physics of course she
went all the way to
get a phd in mathematics and then she
went into teaching
but her family background was military
and so while she was teaching she
eventually decided she needed to move
into
military and join the navy and
she was part of a group called the women
accepted for voluntary emergency service
or waves and six months after
enlisting she was commissioned as a
lieutenant
now this is a statement that she just
really did not like hearing
how many times have you gone into a
company and you've
looked at the stuff that they're giving
you and you're like but why are you
doing it this way and you hear
this line we've always done it that way
we've always done it that way so we have
to continue doing it this way
grace mary hopper did not like that line
at all to her it was one of those
so you've been doing it this way all
along
why there's a better way or an improved
way
or a different way let's take a look and
see what those are
she did not like this line and
rightfully so
if you get stuck doing the same thing
over and over and over again
progress doesn't necessarily happen it's
like doing the same thing over and over
and expecting
different results so she ended up going
on this
trail of success as i call it
she started in her military career
she had a compute coefficients arc
tangents on a mark one
basically what happened is when she
enlisted and showed up
the guy who was running the project was
a fellow professor
and his line and pardon my language this
is exactly what they asked
was where the hell have you been i need
you to go compute those coefficients
i mean to have that kind of welcome he
already knew of her success as
a phd in a mathematician but i think he
was more excited that
she was helping with this
there's she created the 500 page manual
of operations for the automatic sequence
controlled calculator
documentation again i mean seriously
this is awesome
and she eventually moved onto the mark
ii and the mark iii so she worked in the
mark series
she not only did the programming behind
it she also documented it
then she became to this point where she
was on this quest
i call it a quest because i play a lot
of computer games and video games
then they all have quests and so i see
life is there's a quest
and she wanted to find programmer
friendly and application friendly tools
her thought was why do we in the science
world
have to be the ones who have access to
this nobody else have access to this
she wanted it so that computer could be
to a much wider audience
part of her adventures so she went into
private consulting for a little bit
and the company that where she was at
she wanted to
increase collaboration and so they ended
up
writing code and talking with each other
and sharing their code
ran into the whole it reduced the errors
it was less tedious there's less
duplication effort they actually worked
as a team
and they had really good team chemistry
to make things very successful
so to see that kind of collaboration
getting encouraged early on
it's always a good thing she did a lot
of
significant contributions to the
compiler the compiler
had a bunch of mnemonics that they trans
transformed into binary coded
instructions
that only once you have it in binary you
can easily then transfer it over to the
computer
her first compiler that she created was
the ao series
and it allowed us to set call numbers
for routines
and then access those routines from the
call numbers
this was the compiler in the ao series
i'm sure if you deal with compilers
today you know how advanced they've
gotten
but again she wanted to reach out to the
non-scientific reaches as well
she figured well we can open this up to
the world
through programming languages through
refining what ones they were already
using
and also developing new ones
so there is this thing called phlomatic
and yes that's a screenshot of the
phlegmatic code
it looks like it's written in plain
english you see things like
input inventory file a price file b
output price and so this is i guess the
best way to
think of it as programmers is it's
pseudocode
but for them this was their their actual
code
and it was used to work with automated
billing
and payroll calculations so we're moving
out of the science realm and into
business
and what happened with littlematic and
with with admiral hopper's contributions
eventually the univac 1 and the univac 2
understood
at least 20 english statements so that's
flomatic with this like rewind
and read item and right item that's all
english that's stuff that no matter what
programming language we write in today
if you can see this you can probably
write this in your language
but this happened to be the language
that they used for univec one and two
in 1952 admiral hopper published her
first compiler paper
moving on we've got cobalt
admiral hopper was also involved with
the cobalt language design
team cobol if we go back to flomatic
pretty english looking cobalt pretty
english looking
was greatly influenced by flomatic
it was defined by the conference on data
systems languages or codicil
their executive committee in what they
call their short range committee
the first specs came out in 1959
and then there was a big push for
standardizing cobalt an admiral hopper
not only was she tech minded
and had that background in mathematics
but
she wanted to reach out to the people
she also had that
inner ability that some of us don't
always have where she could market it
well
so the companies that she would be
working with she would work with them
including the navy on actually adopting
cobalt
so if any of you guys are still working
on cobalt projects today you can blame
her she did a good job marketing the
language
and so people did start adopting the
club language through her changes she
also would push
forward language validation started with
cobol
and then other programming languages and
platforms also
got it it led to national international
standard
now admiral hopper obviously you're
seeing a lot of significant
contributions
she also taught for the united states
naval reserve while doing all this work
so she's gone she's run the whole gamut
she's done the military side she's a
business she's done academia she's done
private world
she's very well-rounded contributions
she retired from the business world in
1971. i use the word retired loosely
because she continued to work in her 80s
she stayed in the military of course she
was promoted to commodore in 1983
a couple years later the rear admiral
title would merge with the commodore
title
and so then she became an admiral
she retired from the navy in 1986. now
somebody looking at the
slides i just have to make it clear the
only reason why i didn't capitalize
commodore is because i didn't want
anybody to get confused that she was
running promoted to a computer position
not that commodore
in 1992 when she was buried she was
buried with full naval honors
so her military pride that lasted all
her life continued to follow her through
her death
and so some of the things that she had
award wise
in 1969 she got the computer science man
of the year award
i imagine if she were around today she
would probably still respond to hey you
guys
and not be offended i mean at that point
it is what it is
uh 1971 a company that she worked for
sperry they created an award in her name
in 1973 she was the first american and
first distinguished fellow the british
computer society
and these are just some of the awards
she has
all sorts of awards all sorts of
accomplishments there's a grace murray
hopper
conference that acm runs so she's
very well known i mean her influences
you can see in
all different things for the different
aspects of computing today
be it from code optimization to
compilers
to doing any kind of like modeling
with the the symbolic manipulation and
i only put a few things on this slide
the list of her contributions
would fill up that slide and more
so some lessons we've learned from her
just because we've always done it that
way
doesn't mean it's right don't be afraid
to challenge those words
a programming works well as a team task
especially when collaboration happens
and when you bring it down to plain
english computing is not just for
programmers at that point
for mathematicians it's a lot more
approachable
so it doesn't have to be so scary
that's grace murray hopper next thing
we're going to talk about
is not the solid principle you can
ignore that part of the slide
except the orange box that's the list
off substitution principal
liskoff that's a woman in tech
that's barbara liskoff she got her phd
from stanford she was the first woman to
get a phd in computer science from
stanford back in 1968.
and her main focus was computer design
and operating systems
she has received the acm am touring
award
for her work in languages
one of the things she did is she created
this venus computer system
it allowed her to construct complex
software
what was unique about it is that it at
the time allowed
16 teletype connections and everybody
was working in virtual
machines so the reason why she just had
to go with virtual machines is
let's say that this gentleman here that
gentleman there
that lady there are all coming into the
venus system
well if this guy here happens to to
write a system
or a error message or something that
causes the system to die
he only messed his virtual machine he
didn't mess up with that guy or that
lady's
vms so we had virtual machines on this
thing
we're not talking like vmware hyper-v
any of that stuff we're talking back in
the day
virtual machines she also worked on
teams she led teams at mit
for the clu programming language and the
argus program
programming language and if you haven't
heard about them if you
are an acm subscriber and have the
digital library this is from march of
1988.
so clu it's strong things or modular
programming
data abstraction and polymorphism so
what we see in languages like c
sharp and java older languages
much older languages had these and those
have been carried forward
now they don't these the clu and argus
being older languages don't have a lot
of the modern day features
but to have this kind of stuff back then
was neat
argus was mostly focused on distributed
applications
nested transactions as well
this is dr liskoff and these are just
some of the things that she's interested
in focusing in
on from garbage collection
to caching fault tolerance security
so she's all over the board as to what
she's interested in
and what she's contributed to
the mit president has talked about dr
liskoff
being revered in the mit community
because of all of her contributions to
computing
she's not only a scholar but she's also
a mentor
be it to other faculty members or also
to her students
she's also a leader i mean this the work
that she's doing is innovative it's
creative and it's
it's pioneering it's the way that she's
leading it
um as the mit president continued her
pioneering research has made her one of
the world's leading authorities
the computer language and system design
and that's pretty neat
now fran allen fran allen's known for
her compiler contributions
and also dealing with parallel
parallelization so parallel computing
let's keep it easier to say
she has worked with the nsa on
programming languages and security codes
intelligence
i don't know if edward snowden leaked
anything that she worked on
but um in 1989 she became the first
female ibm fellow
she also became the first ibm academy
and president
no ibm was where she
figured she was just going to start pay
off her college bills and be done
and she stayed her whole career there so
she did really good there
she also received an am touring award in
2006
for her performance and
improving performance she's got a lot of
different published works
as we can see here
she did programming optimization
she did the basis of program
optimization
she's dealt with a lot with the compiler
stuff she worked with
a gentleman named john [ __ ] on making
things
work with the compilers and compiler
optimizations
she also worked with fortran and being
able to run fortran in parallel
so if you've ever heard of ptran she's
the one to blame
she did the new new parallelism
detection schemes
it made fortran a lot easier to run
to handle parallel jobs
now let's go a little bit further with
mary lou jepson
she's a little more modern day than our
ada
so her background she's got the
electrical engineering so the
engineering
part i would expect she also has studio
art so she's got
the the analytical mindset and the
creative mindset
which we saw with ada led to some pretty
outrageous things wouldn't you say
to make this even more interesting she's
got a master's in holography
and holograms really
and then a phd in optical sciences so
we've got holograms we've got
optical sciences this could only lead to
some crazy fun stuff right
well nowadays she's the head of the
display division at google x lab
that's google's top secret lab that why
we're calling it top secret when we're
actually talking about it i don't know
but that's their lab she's the founder
of pixel t
which is known for their low cost low
power lcd screens
which is pretty nice to see and she's
also the co-founder of one laptop per
child
how many of you guys have heard of one
laptop for a child
ah it's good to see this many hands so
one laptop per child
basically their goal of course is what
the name suggests they want to
do laptops for children they are
deployed in over 50 other countries
besides the us or in addition to the us
in more than 25 languages every child
in uruguay happens to have one of these
laptops
these xo laptops
they have some light readable displays
so
those amazon kindles and those ipads and
stuff
this stuff is actually a lot easier to
read
they're ultra low power management
what's nice too is they're also the most
environmentally friendly
i believe that i was reading those five
carbon steps
but this is what she did she was a
co-founder
of one laptop for child you can see her
contributions
in various things from holographic video
to projectors to hdtvs
to head mounted displays now i'm not
saying that she contributed to google
glass
because i don't know where she's at in
the google x labs
but this screenshot here of a head
mounted so it looks similar to a google
glass
but something she worked on for another
company this is taken straight off of
her website
so if she was doing that for someone
else and now she's in google it would be
cool if she were working on glass with
that kind of background wouldn't you
think i mean what do you guys think
yeah here's some yeah that's good
so they're i mean these are just a few
of the women that are in tech
but there are so many more i mean we've
got meg whitman
from ebay from dreamworks hasbro
now she's at hp so she's making her
rounds in executive positions
at these tech companies a chemistry
warrior
is currently at cisco she was at
motorola again another
powerful woman in tech anita borg
so she's more known for bringing
non-tech women
into the design room because they have a
different mindset
she's also interested she was interested
in promoting women more
and getting more women in the tech world
because if you think about it there
aren't that many here
um and not saying just here at stranger
but here in the tech industry
as a whole ernest schneider
she invented computerized switching for
telephones
this technology when she invented it was
revolutionary
and here we are many decades later and
it's still being used
then gene samut she came up with the
format programming language
for math for symbolic manipulation and
math stuff
these are just a few more of the ladies
that i happen to squeeze into
my presentation but if you do a search
in your favorite search engine
for women in tech the list nowadays is
endless as to who's there and what
they're doing
so while there are a few of us out there
who are
actually talking about it there are a
lot more who are actually doing things
but there's still not that many we need
to promote more
bring more tell people how much fun it
is to actually do this stuff
so some of the lessons we should learn
from the
women that we talked about today based
on ada's experiences with
charles babbage and his analytical
engine this applies
to everybody not just the women in tech
but choose a member who you're
interested in learning from
and both feed off of their energy be
able to contribute back
to encourage that energy that helps to
bring a really good relationship
and it brings not only you as the mentee
forward but it also brings your mentor
forward as well because it challenges
them keeps them on their toes
um through the women of the eniac keep
an open mind about your career because
you never know where it's going to end
up
i mean you go from ballistics
trajectories to the eniac to the binac
to the univac one
for a lot of them they stayed in
computing
for me i went from tech support
to i.t database administration and
system administration to development
to wherever i choose to go today
so i mean keep an open mind you never
know where that path is going to take
you next
base on grace hopper make tech more
approachable by translating it into
plain english
so if somebody comes up and asks you
what do you do
you oh you write programs what does that
mean
don't say oh i write curly braces and
semicolons
and don't whittle it down to just magic
put it in plain english as to what it is
we do because then
people get more curious if they can
understand what we do
a little bit more they'll ask more
questions then they'll
probably want to get involved in the
field a little bit more it'd be nice to
see a lot more people
getting involved and actually getting
into our
field
and then finally challenge though we've
always done it that way
if there's anything you've gathered out
of my talk make sure
that next time you hear we've always
done it that way to question it
ask yourself we've always done it that
way but why
why do we need to do it that way now
when i can see
this more efficient way of doing things
or this
better way of doing things in one form
or another
don't be afraid because if you don't
take that risk
you're going to get stuck doing the same
thing over and over we might not
necessarily progress
so these are some of the things we've
learned from the women in tech
and i hope you enjoyed our adventures
here if you have any questions please
feel free to find me here at strangeloop
thank you guys
[Applause]